tata moyens de venir ici lui pour
pourvoir mal expression pour moi c'est
une légende
franchement je fous du gars je n'ai
jamais rencontré de ma vie une baie sont
plutôt pas de l'airé et basso cost ou
encore moins de bléré après non mais
vraiment je suis fou de ce gars je n'ai
jamais on voudrait juste que j'ai dit à
aucun de mon temps et j aimerais tu m'as
dit que tu l'appelles parce que je sais
que tu as très très peur de luc besson
lui laissons pour manu ce lundi il peut
plus appeler emmanuel macron n'importe
qui que luc besson c'est trop pas assez
le taulier c'est le taulier donc tu va
l'appeler tu sais qu'on a une carrière
je sais que tu vas lui dire et je vous
jure qu'il est ils n'ont pas prévenu
avant parce que j'étais là et j'ai bien
vérifié qu'il ne renvoyait au cas texto
mic many aller à ça franck tu l'appelles
tu l'appelles en valeur et m'a dit que
tu lui dis faut que je te parle tout de
suite lui qu on a des choses à voir tous
les deux mais un petit truc pression lui
que ça va ouais les chiffres ça va c'est
bon ça se passe bien je suis avec malik
là on est on va rentrer sur château de
nouméa tu sais et il faudrait qu'on vous
voit lui parce que malick il a des trucs
à régler il n'est pas content et encore
je te le passe vite fait contre à l'eau
ou à l'udc
je t'appelle parce que ces êtres banon
est cycliquement taxi c'est vrai c'est
très difficile et moi je suis en train
de péter un boulard non mais je suis si
j'arrive j'arrive plus j'arrive que je
voudrais qu'on se voit chez ohb dans la
prod de ce village où il a bu il ça va
pas en fait il a besoin de te voir
je crois qu'il a un petit pétage de
plomb de l'avant sortie du film tu pas
en train de péter les plombs
la devise non et c'est normalement mais
sans déconner je crois qu'il ne vais pas
bien tatata moyens de venir ici lutte
pour pourvoir mal écrit
bah ouais je vais essayer mais eux la
jugent tout à fait commun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
on est on est tellement heureux de voir
[Applaudissements]
ils n'ont pas nous
souvent vous pouvez pas noir non mais je
vous l'expliquais j'ai eu sept minutes
de pub pendant sept minutes j'ai perdu
un ami mais meilleur va venir mais je
pense qu'il aurait pu lui parler de sa
vie d'homme et ses robes un atelier sur
ma vie ouais vraiment mais j'étais en
panique du mahdia palu insulte le g10
maison à faire insulter le pape jure
même pas qu'elle vous aime parce qu'il
l'a fait par amitié pour vous alors
qu'il était vraiment pas bien pendant
l'année non j'ai trouvé mes dents et moi
je pense ça prouve comment il les
respecte beaucoup mais respectons mais
c'est fou lui qu'il ait jamais rendez
vous raté jeu mais prend effet ça secoue
[Musique]